the cruiser any questions drew I want to
get into a lot of rapid-fire questions
comes to public speaking you know I'm
starting to do more you know speaking
gigs and all of that and the things have
been asked to speak on I've been like
specifically how to's like the you know
the basics for facebook marketing you
know basics for Twitter marketing oh
that type of stuff how do you get into
you know doing talks like you do that
are you know motivational still a little
bit of how to do them for all of that
type of stuff do it for free do you wait
for free like are you doing them for
free now well some of some are free
summer paid depending on the video no I
just tell them what I'm gonna talk about
don't let them dictate what you're gonna
talk about they're gonna say well I want
you to do how to knit be like if you
want me you're gonna get how to but
you're gonna get some other stuff too
period right awesome you know like
people people like hey Gary we want you
to come and motivate people I'm like
listen I love I'm gonna motivate you
regardless cuz motivations blowing out
of my [ __ ] face right true but I want
to give content right so I'm actually
going the other way right like I love
that people want to be motivated in raw
rod and that's great for companies with
morale and issues that danger above the
block but I want to teach as well and
and bring actual value right like let's
get right into it this new book Jab Jab
right hook has to be my best one because
I really tried to make it a utility my
big goal is that that book like this
work I don't know what this is by the
way we're like this book of this
Shepherd I'm in the weirdest place I
can't even tell you I mean some did you
see the booby statue look at the booby
statue up here I mean things are weird
um I'm going a Pinterest meet
everything's are weird but here's what
it is jab the jab right hook is a
utility I literally want it this was Jeb
driver could to that I wanted to be next
to you at all times because I did 86
case studies for this book drew we're
literally I'll teach people what time to
post how to post like I wanted to do it
right right and so um I really want to
make this utility I think Thank You
economy was interesting experience for
me after crush it what crusher was a
little more utility and help people to
use this use this you said thank you
kind of me was very philosophical and
it's been interesting for me to see
actually you know what 800 beeps for the
people that read both book which one
inch at did you like better crusher
Thank You economy and I think the
interesting thing is it like I
we're gonna see more crush its than
Thank You economies but it's interesting
to see why and how and like look I mean
there's Brandi's like it's way better
and so I definitely skewed way more
crush it than T ye here um and so Oh see
I mean it's I think I don't crush it was
great when I you know first read it
because it kind of really got me started
on this thing but you know thank I'm
economy was that next step right where I
was at so like where I've grown in my
career I've kind of been right up
against with where your books have grown
also so my vote is thank you and that's
true honestly and you know what's funny
about that that's why I think JJ RH is
gonna really destroy it because it's so
on it's so right like the reason my
content gets seen more for even my base
numbers the reason we do with the
clients like I'm really excited about a
man like I'm like giving away the secret
sauce that has made vaynermedia go from
20 to 300 people in the last two years
and has really driven business results
for fortune 500 companies but I think
nein i did a good job special and a team
back in vaynor we did case studies of
like lawyers and real estate agents and
small business and celebrities I mean I
don't want to say what I did to Lil
Wayne Weezy's gonna like I'm a little
bit worried that bird man's gonna come
out and kill me after JJ rh comes out I
mean like there's stuff in this book i'm
killing i'm making fun of platforms like
i'm also praising people that I don't
like oh here's a fun fact here's an
exclusive for all the Boston people i
actually had a piece of micro content a
case study in the book making fun of the
Patriots on pinterest but i had to take
it out because at the last minute right
before I went to like Final Cut the
Aaron Hernandez unfortunate situation
happened and Aaron Hernandez's jersey
was part of my micro G said good the
picture of me i had taken out because i
was like tasteless it's a bad situation
so um it's crazy they without like thank
God that it wasn't imprint because it
would have made me look it would have
been like tasteless like so anyway
pretty sure this is one of those case
studies one of your guys contacted me
about a small business that well do you
is that right that's awesome for you
because small businesses mainly got
praised you know um so anyway cool drew
thanks brother